you all have amazing voices
what a weird compliment
[Music]
today we are playing a game where we try
to identify people
based on the sound of their voice i
think i'm honestly going to be really
good at this game because i'm the type
of person that if i'm talking to you on
the phone i'm already trying to guess
how you look like and i'm usually pretty
correct about it
i don't want to offend anyone but i
don't think we will
because i have good intuition i don't
think there's
a correlation between someone's physical
appearance and their voice but i do
think there's a correlation between
the sound of your voice and your vibe i
feel like i'm gonna do mediocre at best
but i'm very willing to try we're gonna
bring in four subjects you're able to
guess two out of four correctly
you're gonna win some candy yay
peter piper picked a peck of pickled
peppers a peck of pickled peppers
peter piper picked if peter piper picked
a peck of pickled peppers where's the
peck of pickled peppers piper
peter pigs peter piper picked a peck of
pickled peppers a peck of pickled
peppers peter piper picked if peter
piper picked a peck of pickled peppers
where's the peck
of pickled pipers peter pepper picked
tony play pack one more time
peter piper picked a peck of pickled
peppers a peck of pickled peppers peter
piper picked
i am not certain with any of this i kind
of feel like you're number three
play me the last one again peter piper
picked a peck of pickled peppers
okay i'm just going for four this is
hard
let me hear just the first half of one
again peter piper picked
a peck of pickled peppers a peck of
pickled peppers
peter piper picked i'm gonna say this
one is number one
because she refuses to make eye contact
with me when it plays
this is harder than i thought duh i
think that you're number one
i get like a number one vibe from you i
feel like i'm wrong already oh god
let's hear two again peter piper picked
a peck of pickled peppers
so you feel like you intentionally
didn't make eye contact with me but then
you looked back at me
so i know if you're trying to throw me
off okay i think you're number two
oh my gosh i really don't even know now
there's no
method to this madness i'm gonna go one
two in order
i feel like this happens
number three please if peter piper
picked a peck of pickled peppers where's
the peck of pickled peppers
peter piper picked see now they're both
making uninterrupted eye contact with me
i've been too vocal about my strategy i
think you're three
oh and i think you're four oh i messed
it all up i know it
i'm gonna swing for the fences and say
they are in order
three and four how did she do
it's right you guys want to swap
you made any mistakes
[Applause]
i don't know why like but immediately
when i heard number one i thought it was
you that was the easiest one but when i
heard the fourth one that really messed
me up because i thought i had it kind of
good until i heard the last one and then
i was like
uh i don't know anymore i really was
confused for the first pass
and i thought it was hopeless that was a
lost cause
those are the only two i was really
confident about though oh yeah
that was my initial thought then i had
to play it again and i was like
oh it's like when you take a
standardized test and you get like
five c's in a row and you're like oh
this can't be right
are they assuming here's the thing
yeah i don't think you played the game
right
if you were going off of our like our
clues not like
our actual voices forgive me for using
the information available
well thank you all for letting me hear
your voices a lot of radio voices i hear
podcasts in your future
[Music]
you